- So wait has your
grandson seen the film yet?
- Not yet no,
but he's seen the character.
- Yeah.
- And he's schooling me on the Sonic game.
- Oh.
- At the moment. Cause I never really
was into video games in a major way.
- Really?
- So yeah.
- Mario Bros for life.
(audience cheering)
I love Mario Brothers.
- Exactly.
- I played Sonic the Hedgehog.
- My daughter was into
Mario Brothers so insanely
that we had to actually
take the game away from her.
Cause it was like crack to her.
- Love her, I'm the same.
- Literally I put it on a shelf
and said a monster broke in.
- Yeah.
- You know that kinda thing.
- I was the same.
- Came in here and stepped on it.
- So you didn't play any video games?
- I played video games,
that's not true I did.
I'm a big Pong fan.
- Okay, okay.
(audience laughter)
- But you know I am trying to
keep up and it is hilarious
because my grandson, we
were playing the other day
and he is just wiping the
floor with me in every respect
and I get angry and I put
money in the swear jar
and stuff like that.
And then I said to him,
I finally got fed up
cause he likes to trash talk me too.
- I love him already.
- Totally and he's nine and
it's really scary and he said,
I said: "You know next
time you come back here,
"I will have practiced and
I'm gonna kick your butt
"like that"
and he said: "Yeah if you
go back and get born again
(audience laughter)
"and start playing at the age of two."
- Cause I'm awesome.
- And I went like: "Who are you?"
What happened here?
- That's awesome.
- Yeah it was pretty fun.
- So wait you spoke about your daughter
and she actually opened for me once.
- We don't need this.
- We don't like that pillow.
I hate that pillow too.
We hate pillows.
- It was comfy on my lumbar.
- But we were talking about
your daughter just a second.
- Yes.
- And she opened for me, like years ago.
- She did, she opened for you.
- Very talented.
- And she wanted me to say
hello and send you her regards,
because she loved you so much.
- Cool daughter though, well done.
She was so cool.
(audience applause)
- She's so great and so talented.
- Yeah.
- Amazing yeah.
- And that's why she's got a
bold kid, cause she's bold.
- Oh no she's smart.
She's been very good council.
You know that the thing that
happens, it switches around,
you know you help them
through their times and stuff
and then sooner or later they
turn around and you're going:
"How do you know that?"
- Yeah, I do that with my five year old.
- They seem like you don't see yourself.
- Yeah, like my five year old
will call me out on something
and I'll be like: "Ooh that
was real, that was true."
- I know, yeah there's no filter.
- That sucks.
- They don't care.
- Yeah.
- I'm like: "I swear I'm a good mommy."
- She's hilarious though.
She told me the other day that
she's never seen scary a
scary moment in a movie.
And I said: "What are you talking about,
"you've never seen a
scary moment in a movie?"
And she told me that every
horror movie she has ever watched
she does this when the scary part comes.
Can you get a close up?
Of my face?
Just come right in, don't be afraid.
- Don't be afraid.
(audience laughter)
So whenever she sees the
scary part in the movie,
she does this.
- What?
(audience laughter)
- So the movie becomes a blur
of a bunch of different images.
- Oh.
- And stuff like that.
So now when I watch
horror movies with her,
it's like "So that was really scary."
- She goes to that place.
- She goes: "Excellent, excellent.
"Really good jump scare there."
- I don't do horrors.
- Hilarious.
- I don't watch them.
- You see then you think
about people doing this,
but not.
- I do this.
See mine isn't really
the visuals, it's sound.
- Really?
- The sound gets me.
I don't watch horror.
I'm like: "Peace out."
- Horrors movies for me are
really not that impactful,
because it can never match
what's going on in here.
(audience laughter)
If I could match what's going on in here,
you guys would be running to the car.
- You're like in your
head like Steven King.
- Yes.
- You're like: "That's crazy."
- Oh yeah, no it's the shining up there.
- Maybe you should walk around a church.
- For sure.
- Just for a bit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah I know.
- Yeah.
- The left side is pursuing
the right side with an ax.
(audience laughter)
- Oh that's my immune system, anyway.